hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute gab es eine überraschende
ankündigung russland verspricht bei den
gesprächen mit der ukraine sie wollen
wohl die militärischen aktivitäten rund
um kiew drastisch herunterfahren ob das
aber ein zeichen für frieden ist dafür
ist dass im moment natürlich noch viel
zu früh um das einschätzen oder sagen zu
können der krieg in der ukraine der seit
über einem monat andauert der ist für
uns ja eigentlich beides sehr weit weg
und gefühlt aber auch manchmal natürlich
sehr nahe und nur sehr wenige würden
vermutlich gerne dort seien gerade aber
das ist tatsächlich das kuriose und
darum geht es in unserer sendung heute
es gibt einige freiwillige die in der
ukraine kämpfen wollen warum deutsche in
der ukraine kämpfen das ist heute thema
bei uns und wir werden in dieser sendung
ein gespräch zeigen mit einem
freiwilligen der sich der ukrainischen
armee angeschlossen hat sein name ist
mad er kommt aus deutschland ist aber
seit vier wochen ganz woanders in der
ukraine im krieg an der front er ist
einer der freiwilligen vielen
freiwilligen aus dem ausland die mit den
ukrainischen soldaten gegen die
russischen truppen kämpfen und im
interview in dieser sendung erzählt uns
mehmet was ihn dazu gebracht hat als
kämpfer an die front zu gehen und was er
dort erlebt und eure fragen und
kommentare dazu wie immer jederzeit
gerne direkt im stream oder einfach per
mail schreibt uns und ich versuche so
viele von diesen fragen dann
aufzugreifen und den expertinnen und
experten und unserer sendung zu stellen
und wir schalten zuerst zu meinen
kollegen jörg brase er ist in der
ukraine in lemberg und er hat mit
männern gesprochen die ihn auch
tatsächlich dort kämpfen wollen hallo ja
guten abend
was sind das für menschen was sind das
für männer die dort getroffen hast die
also aus dem ausland kommen und
tatsächlich dort mitkämpfen wollen wer
ist das
also das sind wirklich ganz
unterschiedliche typen die uns da
begegnet sind also wir haben leute dabei
die tatsächlich über kampf erfahrung
verfügen das sind ehemalige militärs die
dann helfen wollen das sind aber auch
ein paar träume dabei leute die ganze
romantische vorstellungen davon haben
wie es im krieg aussieht wir haben das
gilt für deutsche natürlich auch wir
haben einen deutschen getroffen zum
beispiel bergheim aus dem schwäbischen
der hat eigentlich überhaupt keine
militär erfahrung gehabt und ist dann
einfach hat einfach seinen job gekündigt
ist dann hier in die ukraine gekommen
hat sich dann dort den truppen angeboten
es gibt ja so ein auswahlverfahren muss
man sagen dass mittlerweile auch
professionalisiert worden das heißt das
außenministerium
sammelte an diese menschen in lemberg
hier wo ich jetzt stehe das ist so einer
dieser sammelpunkte wo man sich dann
melden kann dann müssen die leute
fragebögen ausfüllen und dann werden sie
dann noch mal interviewt und was jetzt
für die ukrainische seite wichtig es ist
dass es sich da um leute handelt die man
auch wirklich gebrauchen kann also die
sind auch viele dabei die überhaupt
keine militär erfahrung haben und da
sagt man uns dann auch das ist dann eher
eine belastung als das ist uns hier
hilft oder leute die überhaupt kein
englisch können wie zum beispiel dieser
deutsche dem wir da getroffen haben der
hatte kaum militär erfahrung der hat
auch kaum englisch gesprochen da sagt
man dann müssen wir dem übersetzer geben
dass das ist alles viel zu aufwändig der
war wahnsinnig engagiert er wollte
unbedingt helfen und hat dann auch so
ein traum gehabt dass er dann eine waffe
in die hand bekommt eine militärische
ausbildung und dann eben an die front
geschickt wird und der war total
enttäuscht als man ihm sagte du tut uns
echt leid aber wir können dich hier
nicht gebrauchen wir haben zwei
taiwanesen getroffen die auch überhaupt
kein englisch sprachen haben mit google
translate mit uns kommuniziert und als
ich sie fragte warum seid ihr der nia
warum wollt ihr kämpfen haben sie gesagt
wie hate community und das sind
letztlich leute die mainz alle gut aber
die wurden alle wieder nach hause
geschickt hätte sprichst es an also
leute auch gänzlich ohne jede erfahrung
du hast bilder gedreht da sieht man die
ausbildung wir können sie zeigen aber
allerdings ukrainischer kämpfer denn die
ausbildung der ausländischen kämpfer die
werden wohl gesondert trainiert kannst
du uns ein bisschen mehr aber über diese
ausbildung erzählen und wir zeigen ihnen
die bilder der der ukrainischen kämpfer
nebenbei
ja also es gibt das wurde uns erklärt es
gibt 25 verteidigungs ebenen in der
ukraine
davon sind 3
rationell oder semiprofessioneller
seines natürlich die reguläre armee und
dann gibt es die territorialverteidigung
das sind im prinzip auch reguläre
truppen die auch zu 50 prozent an der
front eingesetzt werden und dann gibt es
noch milizen paramilitärs die auch
militärischen hintergrund haben und
diese ausbildung dieser auch der
territorialverteidigung zugeordneten
gruppen die sehen wir da gerade und was
uns da heute gezeigt wurde das ist eine
kampfausbildung
von vorrangig ukrainischen kräften aber
man muss sich vorstellen dass es auch
diese truppen sind diese soldaten diese
einheiten die wir da jetzt sehen in
denen dann auch ausländer eingesetzt
werden können die ausländer werden
wirklich befragt über ihre ihren
hintergrund militärischen hintergrund
dann wird entschieden können wir die
vielleicht sogar auf ebene 2 einsetzen
also in der territorialverteidigung oder
auf ebene 3 bei diesen milizen oder
setzen wir die dann auch noch weiter
unten ein auf ebene 4 bei der bürgerwehr
die dann letztlich an kontrollpunkten
stehen teilweise auch bewaffnet sind das
wird dann entschieden und dieses
training das findet findet statt man hat
uns heute nur ukraine gezeigt dass da
noch einen grund denn diese
internationale region die hier
aufgestellt wird auch trainiert wird und
dann auf die verschiedenen einheiten
verteilt wird die hat außerhalb von
lemberg in auf einem truppenübungsplatz
trainiert und das hat die hat die
russische aufklärung mitbekommen und hat
dann diese internationalen söldner
legionäre wie immer man sie nennen will
angegriffen dieser truppenübungsplatz
wurde mit raketen beschossen und
daraufhin wird jetzt diese
internationale legion so ein bisschen
aus dem blickfeld geholt und die zeigt
man jetzt nicht mehr öffentlich aber das
sind letztlich leute die da ein
ähnliches training machen wir das was
wir da gesehen haben und dann auch
diesen einheiten den ukrainischen
einheiten zugewiesen werden die
internationale legionen die spielten
unserer sendung gleich noch eine rolle
aber zunächst mal wollen wir gemeinsam
rein hören du hast nämlich mit einem
deutschen gesprochen der jetzt nun also
kämpfen will sie hören mal in das
gespräch und sprechen darüber ich war
noch nie in dieser situation ich war
noch nie im krieg
ich war noch nie im kampf hatte noch nie
eine waffe auf mich gerichtet das
bedeutet all diese emotionen all diese
dinge die man dort verspürt die realität
und die kann ich nicht nachvollziehen
ich kann es versuchen mich diesen
gedanken zu stellen diese angst davor
aber
tatsächlich in dieser situation zu sein
kann ich nicht nachvollziehen und kann
nur versuchen mich bestmöglich darauf
vorzubereiten aber wie ich am ende
reagiere ob ich das schaffe dass meine
ausbildung im training
da entscheidet dass ich handlungsfähig
bin oder eben nicht das entscheidet sich
erst da
das klingt ziemlich naiv ehrlich gesagt
das ist auch ein sehr junger mann den
wir da gerade gesehen haben jörg wissen
die meisten worauf sie sich da einlassen
und sich mann er hat es ja eben schon
fast zugegeben dass er es eigentlich
nicht so richtig weiß er ist 21 jahre
alt er hat zwei jahre bei der bundeswehr
war zeitsoldat bei der bundeswehr war
dann auch mal in der nato einheit mit in
litauen hat der internationale erfahrung
gesammelt aber eben halt keine
kampferfahrung das heißt ja weiß
eigentlich gar nicht worauf er sich
einlässt und er hat uns auch gesagt als
er sich dann verabschiedet hat von
seiner familie zu hause da seien die
völlig zusammengebrochen
und das habe er habe er auch total
unterschätzt also was das jetzt bei
seinen freunden bei seinen verwandten
aus auslöst weil die ja wissen welche
erfahrungen er hat oder eben als auch
nicht hat in der tat also das scheint
mir ein bisschen blauäugig was er da tut
der hat natürlich sehr intelligenter
junger mann der eben eine militärische
ausbildung hat aber keine militärische
erfahrung und das entgeht auch den
leuten hier auf der ukrainischen seite
nicht die sich dann mit ihm unterhalten
die schätzen zwar die tatsache dass er
weiß wie man mit einer waffe umgeht wie
man eine waffe gereinigt wie man sie
bedient dass er auch schon mal
militärische ausbildung gemacht hat aber
er hat halt keine kampferfahrung und das
gilt eben auch hier sage ich mal nicht
als
kriterium um hinterher zu sagen auch
geht ich nehme mir jetzt und die
schicken wir jetzt auch tatsächlich an
die front das risiko geht man hier
glaube ich nicht ein und insofern bin
ich skeptisch ob man ihm dann letztlich
einen papier gibt ob man ihn aufnimmt
und dann tatsächlich hier einsetzt bei
welchen einheiten dann letztlich auch
immer danke für diese schilderung und
danke für die zeit heute jörg brase für
uns live aus der ukraine
und wie auch schon angekündigt am anfang
unserer sendung haben wir nun jetzt also
kommen wir zu dem teil wir haben mit
einem deutschen kämpfer in der ukraine
gesprochen mehmet der also schon an der
front war und wir schauen jetzt mal
genauer ein was er dort genau macht und
wer eigentlich ist
jetzt gerade bin ich seit ungefähr vier
wochen ukraine krieg hier in der
hauptstadt gerade aktiv
ja was mache ich hier ja im grunde
genommen
alles was benötigt wird ja auch bis
jetzt nur essen zu lieferungen sind an
personen die nicht aus den häusern raus
können oder das kämpfen an der front
oder das ausbilden der ukrainischen
soldaten da bin ich bayern
[Musik]
um eine reise begann von deutschland er
gesagt direkt von frankfurt und frank
mit dem schrubber nach berlin kommen wir
liegen aber nach warschau wende und
damit einen nachtzug direkt nach er
im grunde genommen ja habe ich in der
bahn im zug habe ich dann einen herren
kennen gelernt dass ich diese einheit
anschließen heute er hat angefragt ob
ich nicht einfach bekommen will ich
gesagt okay warum nicht und ja wenn dann
im grunde genommen meiner jetzigen
einheit beigetreten ist alles
ausländische kämpfer ja absolut wir
haben gerade noch zwei deutsche aus
deutschland mit dabei eine kompost
nordrhein-westfalen andere
menschen und ja dann haben wir noch eine
magische ehemalige soldaten amerikaner
schweden
spanier franzosen also wir sind sehr
international
[Musik]
ich war bei der bundeswehr hatte auf
einem auslandseinsatz
in afghanistan
ja im jahre 2019 und war dort im grunde
genommen gesteht monate normalerweise
war der einsatz gefahren sechs monate
aber aufgrund vorkommnissen haben wir
uns entschlossen gemeinsam mit der
bundesregierung hat monaten schon zurück
zu ziehen und es ist gerade die aktuelle
meine aktuelle militär
der militärische alltag startet bei uns
um 9 uhr also relativ spät mit einer
bundestag um 6.30 und
ja dann haben wir erst mal unseren
ersten reihen ab sagen wir dazu und ja
haben ein meeting was wir über den
nackten baumann schnee was es neues gibt
und was war im laufe des tages geplant
haben abgesehen davon können anrufe ein
kommen wo wir sofort handeln müssen wir
sofort los müssen bei unterschiedlichen
einheiten helfen müssen ja wir fahren
aber angenommen wie man die frontlinien
haben wir unseren selben lager abchecken
so viele informationen wie möglich
sammeln wenn wir die am telefon bekommt
in unseren scharfschützen an den
radsätzen wo es praktisch ist und dann
im grunde genommen ja
angefragt worden
julia klaus aus unserer zdf heute
redaktion hat dieses gespräch geführt
und ist jetzt bei uns im studio und wir
können mit ihr darüber sprechen und ihre
recherchen hallo julia jetzt ist mehmet
seit vier wochen also teil dieser
internationalen regionen und was ist das
genau was haben wir uns darunter
vorzustellen wer kommt da zusammen ja
also die sogenannte internationale
legion ist ein teil der ukrainischen
streitkräfte
präsident wo leute mir sie lenski hat
die sozusagen ausgerufen und hat
internationale freiwillige ausländische
kämpfer dazu aufgerufen der ukraine zu
helfen
laut ukrainischen angaben sind 20.000
leute haben sich da gemeldet das klingt
erst mal sehr viel tatsächlich können
wir diese zahl nicht nachprüfen und
meine in deutschland gibt es jetzt auch
keine stationären grenzkontrollen das
heißt man könnte jetzt nicht sozusagen
mit zählen wer da irgendwie aus reist
also dass es dass es unklar das
bundesinnenministerium sagt aber dass
sie ausreisen auch theoretisch
genehmigen dass das also nicht illegal
ist wenn deutsche zum kämpfen in diesen
krieg ausreisen dass sie aber
extremisten dass sie diese an der grenze
aufhalten würden
20.000 leute du hast das angesprochen
aber schwer zu überprüfen
wir haben mit mehmet oder du hast mit
moment natürlich viel mehr du hast das
gespräch mit ihm geführt wird auch
darüber gesprochen warum er das
überhaupt machen möchte er hat keine
familie dort er kommt ja selbst gar
nicht mal aus der ukraine und er hat
hier also auch von seiner motivation
erzählt wir schauen mal kurz zusammen
rein
ich habe tatsächlich ein kollegen der
mich darauf angesprochen hat hier
ich habe lust der ukraine zu helfen dann
haben wir natürlich erst mal geschaut in
wie kann man helfen kann ja wir könnten
familien an unseren häusern aufnehmen
wir könnten flüchtlingsfamilien helfen
zu leben dass das absolut richtig aber
unsere unser spezialgebiet ist halt
einfach im kampf und ja mein kollege hat
daraufhin gesagt ich gehe in die ukraine
zu kämpfen hat mich nicht gefragt ob ich
mitgehen möchte oder nicht das war meine
eigene entscheidung ich habe ihm
daraufhin gesagt hier wenn du gehst
komme ich auch war also eine sehr sehr
sehr
kurzfristige entscheidung aber die beste
entscheidung die ich treffen konnte
aber ja meine motivation war es einfach
den kindern gibt zu helfen die aus deren
häuser fliegen müssen den familien den
teilen hinterher weinen die kinder die
in ihren familien erwähnen denen einfach
mal ein bisschen deckung zu geben ein
bisschen stärker zu geben und erst recht
auch zumuten motivieren weil er ist wie
ich gesagt habe wenn wir als fremde in
eine wohnung gehen und einfach nur essen
liefern ja die menschen die freuen sich
sehr darüber werden auch sehr
emotionalen und bedanken sich sehr
herzlich bei uns das ist es was uns
aufzeigt wir machen gerade das richtige
er sagt unter anderem um den kindern
dort zu helfen dass es also einen teil
seiner motivation aber ich glaube um ein
bisschen besser zu verstehen warum man
dorthin geht tatsächlich also auch sein
eigenes leben aufs spiel setzt müssen
wir vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen
mehr über mehmet erfahren was kannst du
uns noch über ihn erzählen was ja ein
sehr langes gespräch auch mit ihm
geführt ja ich hatte jetzt über mehrere
tage
mit ihm kontakt also wir haben
telefoniert
auch dieses video interview geführt
gestern und auch viel geschrieben er hat
mir videos und fotos geschickt
gewisse dinge sind für mich natürlich
nicht verifizierbar ich bin hier erst im
krieg aber
die dinge die er schickt diesem
plausibel also ich habe etwa in einem
telefonat im hintergrund verschiedene ja
so ein bisschen kauderwelsch gehört also
da war ein englisch mit französischem
einschlag und so das heißt die dinge die
er erzählt hat die passen schon zusammen
ich weiß auch ein bisschen was über sein
background in deutschland aber den man
jetzt natürlich hier nicht erzählen kann
weil er möchte anonym bleiben
aber ein bis ins letzte detail lassen
sich bestimmte angaben von ihnen
natürlich nicht überprüfen ja wir haben
auch natürlich schon die ersten fragen
im stream der möchte ich auch gerne kurz
darauf eingehen und zwar schreibt mona
grundmann bei facebook mehmet war bei
der bundeswehr und hat den eid für
deutschland geleistet macht er sich
nicht strafbar du hast ein bisschen dazu
recherchiert was hast du rausfinden
können ja das ist nicht so einfach also
ist es so wenn jemand aktiver soldat ist
bei der bundeswehr dann ist ein solcher
einsatz verboten also man kann nicht
sozusagen aktiv in der bundeswehr sein
und dann bei den ukrainern mitkämpfen
oder bei den russen mitkämpfen das ging
nicht das ist auch so der punkt ich weiß
nicht genau ich habe das nicht schwarz
auf weiß wie er da jetzt ausgeschieden
ist ob er überhaupt ausgeschieden ist
das sagt er dann ist auch die frage ob
er reservist ist an sich ist es
vermutlich nicht illegal aber die das
verteidigungsministerium schrieb mir auf
diese anfrage wenn er tatsächlich nicht
mehr aktiver soldat ist das denn dann
rechtlich ist dass es immer eine
einzelfallentscheidung sei das heißt man
kann das von hier halt einfach schlecht
bewerten ja was das in der vergangenheit
für konsequenzen hatte auch für
freiwillige kämpfer im ausland dazu
kommen wir in dieser sendung noch wo wir
jetzt aber auch noch mal einen ton von
mehmet nämlich vorliegen haben es schon
noch einmal über das was er erlebt hat
und vor allem auch über das
aufeinandertreffen mit russischen
soldaten da hat er davon erzählt wir
haben mal kurz rein
russen wenn man diese festnimmt
möglichkeit hatten festzunehmen
und ja sehr unerfahrenen soldaten auch
seitens des großen also denke ich im
grunde genommen
nicht dass russland da noch mit ihnen
soldaten die dort gerade haben überhaupt
noch eine chance haben es stand 1 2 bei
unserem normalen ablauf ist das ganze so
bevor wir die menschen überhaupt der
polizei oder dem militär übergeben weil
der alte nicht wissen wie kauf reagiert
wird lassen wir die noch mal mit den
eltern telefonieren der mutter mit der
frau mit den kindern telefoniere neben
den natürlich etwas warmes zu trinken
etwas zu essen aber auch als zeichen
hier danke schön dass wir nicht
schließen mussten dankeschön dass ihr
euch ergeben habe
was sagt uns auch einige arbeit ja
sozusagen wegnimmt um ehrlich zu sein
ist das dann schon so dass man
ja in den augen der russen die angst
sieht und einfach aus prinzip was sie
selbst denken hey wir wollen hier
eigentlich gar nicht sein wir sind
gezwungen zu sein verteilt man auch mal
das eigene ärzten und auch mal das
eigene wasser das ist kein problem nach
der festnahme
damit behauptet da jetzt sie würden die
russen gut behandeln ist das auch was
was du in deiner recherche so bestätigen
kannst du bist ja auch auf paar andere
videos gestoßen
ja also wenn man so ein bisschen auf
telegramm unterwegs ist da findet ja
auch damit sehr viel des krieges
sozusagen abgebildet findet man ganz
andere videos und fotos also ich hab
auch diverse fotos gefunden die beweisen
oder die beweisen sollen dass russische
kriegsgefangene eben nicht gut behandelt
werden dass sie beispielsweise
gedemütigt werden dass sie aber auch
verletzt werden ich denke das gehört
vielleicht auch zu jedem krieg irgendwie
dazu leider und das eben auch beide
seiten das vermutlich tätigen weil von
der russischen seite gibt es das
natürlich auch natürlich da gibt es das
auf beiden seiten und die frage ist
natürlich auch so ein bisschen er ist
seit vier wochen schon dort und hat ja
jetzt selbst auch tatsächlich schon
gekämpft
hatte er selbst also auch schon einsätze
wo er tatsächlich menschen töten musste
hatte er davon schon berichtet ja genau
darüber haben wir natürlich auch
gesprochen er wollte da nicht in die
details gehen ich habe ihn auch gefragt
wie viele leute er da vermutlich
umgebracht hat er ist ja auch ein sehr
junger mann wenngleich er militärische
und auch kampf erfahrung hat er hat
gesagt er war 15 mal an der front so
ungefähr in diesen vier wochen und er
hat gesagt er weiß dass er da auch
menschen umgebracht hat wie viele das
weiß er nicht und das wäre auch gar
nicht so genau wissen für sein eigenes
seelenheil dann passt aber hier auch ein
kommentar natürlich weil das sind ja
auch wirklich besorgniserregende
schilderungen von der theorie bei
youtube youtube der schreibt dieser
krieg ist echt und kein computerspiel
hattest du den eindruck im gespräch
jetzt mit mehmet dass ihm das aber
natürlich auch die ganze zeit so real
vor augen ist er
wirkt auf mich gefasst er wirkt auf mich
dass er die dinge die da erlebt relativ
neutral vielleicht auch etwas
emotionslos beschreibt dazu passt auch
etwas das er von sich selbst sagt dass
er eine ptbs hat das ist eine
posttraumatische belastungsstörung
er sagt dass er das oder vermutlich hat
er das aus seinem bundeswehreinsatz das
lässt sich einfach nicht überprüfen
ich habe aber dass ein militär
psychologen gefragt vom
bundeswehrkrankenhaus ulm und er hat
gesagt was auch immer er hat wenn es
ihnen nicht gut geht ist es natürlich
eine zitat aktive selbst schädigung da
jetzt zurück zu gehen und sich sozusagen
wieder so einem trauma auszusetzen das
kann mit schlafstörungen et cetera
einhergehen und er hat gesagt er muss
sofort aus dem krieg zurück und sich
behandeln lassen
es gibt auch noch eine spannende frage
von wie etwa youtube wird mehmet für
seinen dienst vergütet habt ihr darüber
gesprochen
theoretisch wäre das wohl möglich er hat
auch einen vertrag unterschrieben aber
er sagt er erhält keinen sold freiwillig
das hat mich auch verwundert
also das heißt er sagt er kämpft da
sozusagen for free und erhält keine
bezahlung
das was er uns schildert und was du
natürlich jetzt aus dem gespräch
schildert klingt ja auch nicht so dass
das menschen ohne erfahrung machen
sollten no mercy schreibt dazu bei
youtube es gibt eine sache die mich
wundert nicht kampffähigen menschen
könnten doch anderweitig helfen in der
logistik oder ähnliches werden
unerfahrene nach hause geschickt dazu no
mercy am anfang unserer sendung hatten
wir durchaus gehört von dem kollegen
jörg brase dass da also auch nicht jeder
kämpfen darf das war am anfang teil
dieser sendung aber vielleicht also
jetzt noch mal ganz klar auch zum bett
und zu seiner zu seiner motivation das
ist ja das was uns allen vielleicht ein
bisschen schwer fällt auch das zu
verstehen hast du ihn fragen können auch
warum er sich das also warum er jetzt
noch mal wieder in einen krieg zieht
nach seinen erfahrungen in afghanistan
warum tut man sich sowas ja das für mich
etwas paradox klingende was er gesagt
hat war dass der krieg auch so ein
bisschen wie eine medizin für ihn ist
dass es auch ein zitat die begründung
war dass er eben davor bestimmte
probleme hatte also zum beispiel
irgendwie schlafstörungen und dass die
jetzt weg sein jetzt wo er im krieg ist
das ist sicher nicht seine seine
motivation sozusagen seine einzige wir
haben ja auch im ersten einspieler
gehört warum er das machen weil er hat
gesagt er will den leuten da helfen
und ja aber dass das hat er mir noch
erzählt ja vielen dank für die
einordnung und für seine recherchen
heute julia wir können jetzt auch noch
weiter sprechen über eben das was ich
schon angesprochen habe dass uns das
natürlich schwer fällt auch zu verstehen
warum menschen dorthin gehen wir haben
jetzt die möglichkeit mit julia ludwig
zu sprechen von der universität potsdam
sie forscht zum einsatz freiwilliger
deutscher kämpfer und hat sich auch
schon in der vergangenheit in
vergangenen kriegen mit diesem thema
beschäftigt also der motivation schönen
guten abend frau ludwig
und können sie uns ein bisschen mehr
darüber erzählen was sie in ihrer
forschung schon herausgefunden haben was
was treibt menschen dazu tatsächlich
also dort in den fremden krieg zu ziehen
also wie wir das fordern jetzt auch
schon durch die beiträge
in verschiedener hinsicht dargestellt
bekommen haben es ist letzten endes
heterogene gründe also unterschiedliche
motivationen weshalb menschen sich jetzt
da auf den weg machen um ihre freiwillig
in den krieg zu ziehen das können
faktoren sein wie ein gewisser hang zum
abenteurertum und da hilft jetzt
sozusagen auch dass der krieg mehr oder
weniger vor der haustür ist dass man
sozusagen relativ unkompliziert mit dem
auto oder mit dem bus oder mit dem zug
mit öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
sozusagen an die front fahren kann mit
relativ wenig aufwand also verglichen
mit anderen situationen dort irgendwie
kämpfen kann man macht so eine art
aufnahmeprüfungen und besteht dann und
kann theoretisch münchen kämpfen dann
aber auch faktoren wie idealismus dass
es also personen gibt die einfach sagen
ich sehe das hier unrecht geschieht und
ich bin der meinung ich musste
eingreifen ich kann ja nicht nur
zuschauen oder ich kann ja auch nicht
nur um geldspenden meinetwegen sondern
ich muss da aktiv was tun also dieses
gerechtigkeit verschaffen vielleicht in
einem gewissen sinn dann aber auch
faktoren die sagen wir mal politische
hintergründe haben dass wir also
personen haben was wir vorher aufgehört
haben antikommunisten oder personen die
auf irgendwelchen anderen gründen ebenso
zu sagen gegen gegen russen
beispielsweise vorgehen wollen
militärisch also viele hand gründe die
dazu führen können dass jemand da jetzt
freiwillig im krieg sich engagiert dass
menschen also aus dem ausland freiwillig
in andere kriege ziehen das ist nicht
neu das gab's in syrien krieg das gab es
im jugoslawienkrieg dazu haben sie
insbesondere auch geforscht was ist da
aus der vergangenheit auch bekannt jetzt
von menschen die dorthin gegangen sind
sind die wieder zurückgekommen sind die
teilweise dort geblieben sie haben da
unterschiedliche biografien gehört was
können sie uns dazu berichten
ja da gibt es auf jeden fall ganz
unterschiedliche umgangsweisen damit und
eine haben wir jetzt gerade auch gehört
von männern eine werbung zu sagen ich
komme so zu sagen nach meinem
kriegseinsatz nicht mehr klar mit der
zivilen gesellschaft und der zivilen
realität also wahrlich
kulturanthropologie spricht man eben von
kulturschocks die da in dem kontext
stattfinden also einmal zum 1 eintritt
in den krieg das ich na ja ich sag mal
wirklichkeiten verschieben sachen die
vorher im zivilleben wichtig waren die
spielen keine rolle mehr also niemand
denkt darüber nach auf rechnungen
bezahlt werden oder so stattdessen
versucht man einfach den tag zu
überleben das führt aber auch dazu dass
wenn diese person dann aus irgendwelchen
gründen nicht mehr in dieser realität
des krieges sind sei es weil der krieg
zu ende ist oder weil sie aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht mehr kämpfen
können weil sie verletzt wurden oder so
dann führt das dazu dass sie oftmals
schwierigkeiten haben sich in der
zivilen realität wieder zurück
zurechtzufinden und manche kompensieren
das dann damit leben dass sie wie er
jetzt vom krieg spricht als medizin dass
er sozusagen sich wieder in so eine
situation begibt weil er so sehr an
gewöhnt war an diese situation lassen
für ihn jetzt im ersten moment leichter
erscheint als als die zivile realität
und sich darin wieder zurechtzufinden
sozusagen andere wiederum das waren sie
insbesondere jetzt person die ich
interviewt hat für die jugoslawienkriege
wir sind vor ort geblieben also im
gebiet des ehemaligen jugoslawien weil
sie einfach gesagt haben sie fühlen sich
dort heimisch als in ihrer ehemaligen
heimat gesellschaft einfach weil sie mit
den menschen den zivilisten die
ähnliches erlebt haben wie sie gefühlt
mehr gemeinsam haben sich da mehr
aufgehoben und verstanden fühlen als
zurückzukommen in die zivilgesellschaft
wie unsere die zum glück muss man ja
sagen seit dem zweiten weltkrieg eine
kriegserfahrungen keine kriegserlebnisse
mehr direkt eben erlebt hat und dadurch
ist ja sozusagen eine gemeinsame ebene
geschaffen worden was den leuten eben
hilft sich darin besser zurechtzufinden
wir haben eine spannende frage bei
youtube ein thema über das wir noch
nicht gesprochen hatten von pera hockey
er oder sie möchte wissen wie wird das
vertrauen der freiwilligen
sichergestellt dass keine dass keine
spione eingeschleust werden
das ist auf jeden fall eine schwierige
frage
insofern als dass ich sagen kann dieses
milieu oder diese gruppe
kriegsfreiwilliger allgemein wenn man
jetzt von der gruppe sprechen kann ist
grundsätzlich eine sehr misstrauische
gruppe dies sehr misstrauisch gegenüber
außenstehenden gegen über personen die
jetzt als außenstehende damit dazu
kommen das heißt auch selbst im krieg
sind die sehr misstrauisch gegenüber
neuankömmlingen sozusagen und die werden
erst mal auf die probe gestellt also im
krieg damals in jugoslawien waren die
strukturen etwas anders als jetzt in der
ukraine aktuell sind wir haben jetzt in
der ukraine schon ihre situation dass
die akteure in gewisser weise in die
institutionen in das militär der ukraine
eingegliedert sind das war im
jugoslawienkrieg anders und dadurch war
natürlich auch die frage noch viel
stärker was ist das jetzt für eine
person wieder zu uns kommt was hat die
für beweggründe und ist die sozusagen
vom verhaltenskodex auf demselben level
wie dem verhaltenskodex den wir für uns
als akteure eben festlegen
dementsprechend ist das mit der
vertrauenssache auf jeden fall ein ganz
großer faktor ich glaube es gibt keinen
kontext außerhalb des militärs in dem
halt kameradschaft und natürlich damit
auch das vertrauen sein leben dem
kameraden eben an vertrauen zu müssen im
zweifelsfall den viel höheren
stellenwert hat als irgendwo anders und
dadurch ist natürlich auch der faktor
vertrauen und dass man eben eine
gemeinsame ebene hat sehr sehr wichtig
zum schluss noch die frage die auch
spannend ist werden wir auch schon in
syrien krieg als einen der kriege
angesprochen wo eben auch freiwillige
aus dem ausland angereist sind um dort
mit zu kämpfen wie groß ist denn die
gefahr aber auch tatsächlich von einer
vielleicht auch radikalisierung vor ort
dass man sich also auch gruppierungen
anschließt die eben radikal sind was
können sie uns darüber erzählen
also der faktor radikalisierung der
spielt natürlich in gewisser weise meine
rolle es gibt sowohl in der ukraine als
auch damals in jugoslawien als auch bei
syrischen
freiwilligen natürlich die tendenz dass
sich dort leute eben zusammentun die
sagen wir mal in irgendeiner form
extremistisch sind sei das jetzt
rechtsextrem oder vielleicht in der
islamistische richtung die gefahr
besteht man muss natürlich jetzt da aber
auch unterscheiden
nicht jeder der da hingeht kann auch
kann auch kämpfen also ist wird sowohl
aufgenommen vom militär das hatten wir
jetzt vor neben gehört das durchaus
nicht jeder der jetzt kämpfen will auch
kämpfen kann das auch leute nach hause
geschickt werden dann habe auch wie es
überhaupt dazu in der lage längere zeit
an der front wirklich direktes gefechts
geschehen auszuhalten also auch mental
auszuhalten und ich habe in vielen
erzählungen von personen mit denen ich
gesprochen habe gehört dass es letzten
endes eigentlich keinen unterschied
großartige macht ob man jetzt über jahre
hinweg vielleicht sogar eine sehr sehr
militärisch auf kampf ausgerichtete
ausbildung gehabt hat dass sich die
sache dann aber immer erst im
kriegsgeschehen selber eben zeigt ob
jemand mental und auch sonst überhaupt
in der lage ist das was er sozusagen an
eindrücken auf ihn einprasseln zu
verarbeiten und dann eben nicht in
schockstarre zu fallen und eben nicht
handlungsfähig zu sein und genau so gab
es aber personen die vorher eigentlich
keine großartige militärische
vorausbildung hatten die aber sich
sozusagen in der gefechtssituation als
sehr resistent uns als sehr
anpassungsfähig erwiesen haben und sehr
sehr gut damit umgehen konnten also
heißt es letzten endes nichts anderes
als dass es im grunde genommen vorher
erst nicht klar ist ob diese person sei
sie noch so gut ausgebildet dem was auf
sie einprasseln wird überhaupt gewachsen
ist und
entsprechend was die radikalisierung
angeht kann es auch aussagen dass es
eben personen sind die vorher von der
gewissen ideologie oder was auch immer
überzeugt sind aber dann letzten endes
um gefechts geschehen sehr schnell
feststellen dass sie dafür gar nicht
geeignet sind und dann auch relativ
schnell wieder aus dem krieg wieder
zurückkommen in ihre heimat aus
gesellschaft hat man natürlich so ein
bisschen das problem dass man versuchen
möchte solche personen möglichst nicht
an waffen auszubilden und denen
natürlich auch keine kampferfahrung
zukommen zu lassen die frage die sich da
halt immer stellt ist ob dem tatsächlich
so ist und wie viel davon vielleicht
auch so ein bisschen durch die medien
eben
aufgebauscht wird das dass es eben
vorwiegend leute sind aus dem
rechtsextremen milieu eine ihr
pazifistisch eingestellte gesellschaft
im deutschen kontext
neigt man halt eben dazu dass sozusagen
ein bisschen an den rand der
gesellschaft zu drängen damit man in
gewisser weise hat eine erklärung dafür
hat warum menschen so was jetzt tun und
man tut sich damit leichter zu sagen das
sind ausnahmeerscheinungen oder das sind
radikalisierte als zu sagen das ist
irgendwo ein stückweit jemand er mein
nachbar sein könnte und jeder
theoretisch irgendwie in der lage wäre
in den krieg zu ziehen und auch bestand
zu haben wird
vielen dank für ihre einordnung julia
ludwig von der universität potsdam danke
ihnen sehr gerne und wie lange dieser
krieg noch andauert das weiß natürlich
niemand und auch wie lange die
freiwilligen dann noch dort in der
ukraine kämpfen werden kämpfen wollen
mehmet hatte unserer kollegin julia
klaus erzählt er wolle bleiben bis der
krieg zu ende ist und dann auch noch
beim aufbau helfen danke euch für die
aufmerksamkeit und eure fragen und seit
gerne morgen wieder dabei bis dahin
tschüss